bonsoir françois grosdidier merci de
répondre à nos questions au lit avant la
visite d'olivier véran vendredi dernier
à metz vous appeliez un confinement
localiser vous n'avez pas été écoutés le
week-end passé dans quel état d'esprit
est ce que vous êtes
excédé comme votre homologue dunkerquois
bien sûr assez en colère parce que nous
connaissions bien la situation sur le
terrain nous observons le comportement
de nos administrés nous sommes en
relation constante avec le corps médical
dans les hôpitaux dans la médecine
libérale et on n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi on n'est pas compris lorsque le
ministre de la santé venus vendredi
il semblait ouvert il a pu constater la
gravité de la situation le dialogue
était et est intéressant avec lui mais
on s'est vite rendu compte qu'il ne
déciderait rien et qu'il remettait des
six à une réunion du soir en présence du
président de la république les décisions
il nous paraissait absolument
indispensable d'une part d'accélérer le
mouvement de vaccination
on ne peut pas vaccinés au même rythme
d'ailleurs trop lent tous les
départements sur les systèmes embarqués
travers les formes aux allemands pardon
il va y avoir 30 mille doses
supplémentaires qui doivent arriver en
moselle alors nous avons d'abord et
tonton d'huile avait annoncé l'après
midi même 2000 vaccins en plus qui était
dérisoire parce qu'il faut rapporter une
population d'un million d'habitants et
de plus de 100000 habitants de plus de
75 ans donc avec 30000 aujourd'hui ça
commence à être sérieux mais cela dit
nous maintenons nos demandes ou pour 1
re confinement locale est très court ou
au minimum pour une avancée des vacances
scolaires parce que ces vaccins
ils vont pas être injecté en une journée
ni même en une semaine au rythme pris
par les autorités de santé
ces semaines précédentes et surtout même
s'il était injecté en une journée ils
mettraient quinze jours à produire de
l'effet or pour nous il ya urgence à
freiner à inverser le la tendance est à
freiner l'épidémie tout de suite c'est
pour ça que même à défaut d'un
le confinement dans l'état ne veut pas
entendre parler pour ne pas avoir à
indemniser le chômage partiel on
attendait au moins une avancée d'une
semaine des vacances scolaires
parce que le variant se se répand
beaucoup plus chez les jeunes notamment
chez les 10 20 ans que lakovic 19
classique chaque cas positifs au coït 19
sera considéré comme un variant avant la
preuve du contraire c'est suffisant ou
pas selon vous sa suffisance ça
n'empêche pas cessé heureusement que
l'on fait seul compte tenu de
l'explosion des cas de variants chine ou
mais il suffit pas de le considérer
comme un invariant pour ralentir la
progression pour ralentir la progression
il faut éviter les contacts et faut
éviter les contacts sur ceux qui ont le
plus de mal à respecter les gestes de
prudence qui sont les jeunes pour la
tous été jeunes c'est très difficile
pour des des élèves de primaire et même
pour des collégiens ou des lycéens de
porter le masque et de respecter la
dissociation pendant une journée entière
on sait d'ailleurs que c'est peu
respectée quoi et on peut pas en vouloir
à ces jeunes bon mais simplement quand
il y a le feu
il faut prendre des mesures immédiates
et donc c'est les sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont présents dans votre département
pour dépister dans dans les eaux usées
comment est-ce que vous accueillez 7,7
cette action positivement aussi menacer
palais les pompiers pour éteindre le feu
c'est très bien eux mais c'est eux les
pompiers de marseille pour examiner la
présence de deux variants ou pas et
c'est une mesure de prévention qui est
positive et qui doit nous aider à mieux
cerner le problème
donc tout cela est utile comme les
vaccinations ça n'empêche pas qu'il
aurait fallu dès cette semaine un coup
d'arrêt un coup de frein brutal et le
coup de frein brutal jusqu'à présent le
seul qui ait fait ses preuves ça a été
seul le confinement et à défaut d'un
confinement c'était au moins d'avancer
d'hespel et la rentrée scolaire alors
les mesures comme ce mouvement de
vaccination qui va progressivement
l'airé où les mesures qui vont nous
permettre grâce aux pompiers de
marseille peut être d'identifier plus
précisément ce phénomène que pour
l'instant nous n'expliquons pas quoi
qu'il soit clair que les quatre variants
ça nous est arrivé et il est depuis hier
depuis maintenant un peu plus d'une
semaine qu'un jour on n'arrive même pas
à établir clairement la traçabilité en
amont ne comprend pas pourquoi les
jeunes sont plus exposés on sait pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi il vient c'est le
vaillant sud africain qui arrive en
moselle on a plus de mal à comprendre
l'avarié en anglais à dunkerque dans la
certitude totale
toutes ces investigations sont bonnes
mais ces investigations ne produisent
pas encore l'heure d'été comme les
mesures de prévention supplémentaire
avec la vaccination ne ne dispose pas
pour autant de nous protéger tout en
filmant mais est ce que vous comprenez
la population qui serait peut-être
mécontente d'un confinement à cause des
répercussions économiques sociales et
psychologiques ne met pas du tout ce qui
mine psychologiquement la population
c'est pas un confinement cours qui pour
eux ses effets de couvre-feu
interminable je dois vous rappeler que
nous avons commencé avant les autres
départements ce couvre-feu qu'on
l'avancé à 18 heures certains même
reparle de l'avancé à 16 heures ça
exerce une pression sur ses salariés qui
n'ont pas le temps de faire quelques
courses et de récupérer les enfants
inventent rentrer chez eux
ça tue plus plus sûrement les
commerçants qui ne sont pas indemnisés
en chômage technique et qui perdent
entre 1,15 et trois quart de leur
chiffre d'affaires selon les types de
commerces eux-mêmes en soi dire mais
mais confiné nous pour de bon sur une
période courte plutôt que cette
interminable couvre-feu qui produit même
des effets contre-productifs puisque en
précipitant les genres même endroit au
même moment dans les transports en
commun ou dans les magasins et est bien
en a plutôt une accélération de la de
l'épidémie si j'en crois la récente
étude du céreq chu de toulouse
dernière question à françois grosdidier
l'allemagne voisine
ferme ses frontières à la république
tchèque et au tyrol autrichien
berlin dit surveiller de près la moselle
single i'm here calvente a fermé ses
frontières avec votre département
comment est-ce que vous réagiriez leurs
députés agir la droite constructif
fabienne keller il voit un non sens car
selon elle le virus ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières
votre votre réaction dans le virus ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières mais le
virus est porté par des personnes qui
franchissent la frontière
donc effectivement que c'est très
difficile de bloquer les frontières je
vous rappelle qu'en moselle département
d'un million d'habitants nous avons plus
de cent mille travailleurs frontaliers
avec luxembourg avec l'allemagne que
d'ailleurs le luxembourg avait en amont
a un moment envisagé de fermer la
frontière avant de se rendre compte que
70 % des soignants au luxembourg en fait
habiter en france et veut bosser au
luxembourg donc ça ne tient pas par
contre ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
l'allemagne art confiné est ce que le
luxembourg à fermer des écoles dort
effectivement ils peuvent nous reprocher
de ne pas exercer les mêmes mesures de
précaution que même dans une gestion peu
plus souple plus agile plus
décentralisée plus réactive alors qu'en
france tout comme ça nous sommes sous le
règne d'un centralisme bureaucratique
très déphasé par rapport à la réalité de
terrain
on a eu quelques semaines on a eu le
droit aux couples préfet le maire et je
suis maire de mèze président des maires
de moselle se pouvait que me féliciter
de la marge de manoeuvre laissée aux
préfets à ce moment là mais ça n'a duré
que quelques semaines et le naturel est
revenu au galop et et ce centralisme
bureaucratique a repris tous ses droits
merci françois grosdidier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes maire les républicains de metz
en moselle